>> If you look at the higher
primates, bonobos, chimps,
most notably, you do find --
what I think is a very
impressive ability
to communicate.
Now it's not typically
through vocalizations.
One of the curious things
that distinguishes humans
from non-human primates is that
we have a very fine control
over our mouths, our
articulators, in fact,
even our ability to breathe.
I'm told by primatologists
that if you drop a chimpanzee
in a swimming pool,
it'll sink like a stone.
They can't be trained
to hold their breath.
But they can communicate
manually through sign language.
And they can understand
spoken language.
So Kanzi, who is a bonobo,
is very well studied.
I want to show you a bit of
what Kanzi does and then ask you
to think about how
to understand that.
This is Kanzi as a cute,
little bonobo baby.
Cute, little bonobo
babies grow up to be not
so cute bonobo adults.
And this is Sue Savage-Rumbaugh
who has worked with Kanzi
over many, many years to teach
Kanzi to sign and, in fact,
to understand her language.
So let's look at a clip of Sue
Savage-Rumbaugh in the kitchen
with Kanzi working together.
>> I got the onions in a bowl.
Let's go put them
in our hot food
and we'll come back
and turn the TV on.
Put your onions right here
and put them in your bowl.
Look. You spilled some of them.
>> The chimps have responded
well to such a rich environment
and show an unprecedented
grasp of spoken English.
>> Let me get you a spoon
to stir it with Kanzi.
>> In addition to
spoken language,
they receive a steady
stream of nonverbal cues,
attention directing maneuvers,
and repetition, the hallmarks
of the way we speak
to young children.
>> Yeah. Will you wash
this potato off for me?
Could you wash the potato?
>> Sue Savage-Rumbaugh is
convinced that the combination
of all these every
day interactions
at an early age is essential
for the acquisition of language.
Scientists call this
process enculturation.
>> All right.
Your noodles are
going to go in here.
And you can have a few
of them for your tummy.
Kanzi could you turn the
water off again please?
Turn the water off please.
>> In the kitchen,
in Sue's company,
Kanzi functions impressively.
But does Kanzi, like a human,
really have the ability
to understand words?
>> And that's the question.
What is it exactly
that Kanzi understands?
Now I take it as very impressive
that Kanzi can function
in a kitchen and interact
with Sue in all of the things
that are needed to do to cook.
Kanzi spent a lot of
time in the kitchen,
so this is not the first
time Kanzi has done this.
But put yourself in
Kanzi's place or better yet,
put yourself in some unfamiliar
language context, pick Farsi
or Hungarian, and
imagine you were working
with a Farsi speaker.
And you knew a few words:
onions, water, things like that.
You probably would get fairly
far and be able to do the kinds
of things that Kanzi did based
on the knowledge of a few words
and based on knowing
what's appropriate behavior.
Okay. So without
meaning to belittle
or diminish the impressiveness
of what Kanzi is doing,
it's probably -- this, at least,
is not a conclusive
demonstration that Kanzi is able
to use language in any
of the complex ways
that we normally think about it.
And we'll talk a bit about
what that might mean.